thank you
welcome back I think this might be one
of the most popular things to do right
now totally yeah and that is to follow
your family's history back generations
to learn more about your ancestors and
their stories I mean my family's so
important to me oh right I feel so
connected to them so I love this and who
better to team up with and take us on
that Journey than ancestry yeah ancestry
yeah we know them they want to help
people and their loved ones learn
meaningful new things about their
families and discover their stories and
both Drew and I recently took the
ancestry DNA test we have no idea what
the results are but here to take us
through our results and our family
histories is ancestry's family historian
Lisa Elsie hi Lisa
so we did the DNA test and you ran it
through your lab what did you find out
about it so let's start with you let's
start with your ancestry DNA results
okay so you come from seven different
regions across the world your highest
region is 47 from Norway then you have
19 of your DNA from England and then 14
from Sweden and Denmark and then nine
percent Finland I'm like that Muppet
that's hard to hurt
a lot of Scandinavia I did know that I
mean my whole family yeah Scandinavia we
eat things at Christmas like ludafest
and things like that all Scandinavia so
I did know that just because my my
grandma my bunker who watches every day
96 hi bunker she's a proud Scandinavian
she has good genes yeah she does where
am I from okay so Drew your ancestor DNA
results your highest percentage is from
Ireland at 34 we were able to pinpoint
the region your family's from in Ireland
it's called Munster munster's on the
very western part of Ireland okay and
it's remote location made it the perfect
place for refuge for Irish Outlaws who
rebelled against their English leaders
so much so that even the city of cork in
that region was called Rebel City
it's in your DNA everybody go get an
ancestry kit right now
[Applause]
but then 19 of your DNA also comes from
Eastern Europe and Russia that's my mom
yeah my mom
um has that Hungarian blood and DNA and
I highly respect it yeah so Drew you
obviously know a lot about your family
history already yeah but we wanted to
give you a few things through ancestry
just to add to your family's Story
please so we have a newspaper article
that was kind of the last billing of
your third great-grandmother who was
named Eliza troutner Lane kinlock and
the headline said oldest actress in the
world she was 91 at the time of her
death in Philadelphia go on Ross because
I I just need to ponder my whole
existence that makes so much sense yeah
Rebel City over here okay well what did
you find out about my family you
actually have a lot in common with your
grandmother Betty Louise lindbaugh
that's bonka for instance you were
married last year to Wellington Garcia
may 2022. look at us yes
and I believe you had orchids like on
the table white yes white orchids your
grandmother was married in 1946 and we
found out through a newspaper article
about her wedding she also had orchids
at her wedding
she had a white bouquet of orchids for
her wedding oh I'm gonna call her about
comes full circle does it help you feel
like it makes life make sense like I'm
from Rebel City level yeah so Ross did
you know that your namesake actually
comes from your father's side of the
family no I had no idea really you're a
great grandfather's name was Ulysses
Ross Matthews
wow and here's his World War II draft
registration card showing what so my dad
we never knew his his father and so this
is all news to me I asked my mom how she
named me and she just said she thought
it was fun that it was one syllable be
easy Ross done you guys this is so cool
holy history can be something that like
we can all do together I love bringing
everyone from this show or out there in
the world I just want this to be a
collective experience whoever you are is
welcome here and it also makes a very
good gift so we're giving our entire
studio audience and ancestry DNA kit
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]